je vais vous faire une interview nul
pour ne bouge pas dans le jingle
le bouger josé noah n'a pas bougé si la
bougie et voulzy la moustache bien alors
intervenu là je vous préviens si vous
préférez staline ou hitler
c'est vraiment rude comme questionnons
insérée dans
mais c'est mort ou vif est ce que vous
préférez votre père votre mère ah oui
c'était je vous ai dit attendez je les
avertis celle intervenue la ligne ça
dépend des jours
grâce à lui et entre mon père ou ma mère
vous préférez qui le fuit sa santé je
vous ai déjà mangé du surgelé dans un
igloo non est-ce que vos vêtements vous
les préférez d'étain ray tracing
déchirait aura des temps
c'est un coup monté vahidi pas les
fringues pas la famille josé console
concentrez vous quel est d'après vous
l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
l'homme bien c'est pas alors maintenant
à un dilemme assez compliqué un ami
débarque chez vous à l'improviste
qu'est ce qui vous gêne le plus qu'ils
trouvent sur votre table de nuit
mein kampf ou un godemiché mein kampf
ah oui dans le larzac cinq ans à
montredon du lardin quand même qu'on
n'ait pas pu faire la même rêve ou
presque est souvent c'est ça soit pas
trop ce que tu imites là une question
que ses deux amis composé jeu lundi sur
comédie un chauffeur vous êtes chauffeur
routier
vous êtes mais j'ai un port de les
fréquenter un vous êtes chauffeurs
routiers vous perdez le contrôle de
votre véhicule et il ya une grande
descente et vous écrasé sur une maison
ou sur une autre
d'un côté il ya votre maison avec votre
femme et vos enfants et l'autre côté il
ya une école primaire
vous vous écrasez sur quoi c'est tout
non c'est juste ou pas qu'est ce que
l'on sait c'est que mes fonctions celle
là je sais qu'il a inventé moi je saute
avant comme ça j'ai pas réfléchi à fait
d'accord mais bon